Y = bx + a, the key holy grail in linear regression and in much of  statistics is
how to use data to determine the value of b and the value of a.
So if you can do this with data, then we solve the problem of fitting the best line
and that's once again called linear regression.
So I won't give you the derivation but I'll give you the formula. Let's start with b.
Assuming your data comes in pairs for x and y as indicated here
and the formula for b might look really complex at first but I promise you it isn't.
Just in the calculations of the variance, we take the difference between x and the mean of x,
but rather than squaring this as in the variance case, we now do a product with the same term for the y's.
So important here, this notation x-bar is the mean of the Xi and x-bar is the mean of the Yi.
Previously, we would have called x-bar µ
but now that we have two variables we're going to use the bar notation.
Let's go back and look at this formula here.
When we computed the variance, we would have taken (Xi - X-bar)²
but here we're taking the product of Xi - X-bar multiplied by the y direction of the same thing.
So it's similar to computing a variance. The last thing we do is normalize this thing.
Before we often normalize with n but now we're going to normalize with something else.
We normalize with the term that very much reminds us of the variance.